remember having fun you know like at
theme parks
roller coasters
well apparently they're coming back but
maybe not quite as fun as you might
remember them california has announced
it will reopen its theme parks
but on the condition that people will
stay dead silent
while zipping through the air on their
favorite roller coasters
so basically defeating the whole point
of the ride if you're having trouble
imagining just how depressing boring
and sad a silent rollercoaster ride
could be
well japan introduced a similar rule
last summer
and it was about as fun as you could
expect
wow much fun and keeping in line with
the whole
covet thing a bunch of other measures
were also introduced
such as how many people can be on a ride
seating pattern
the amount of households that can be on
one train you get the idea
so basically it's we're open but
we might as well not be because all the
measures we're gonna introduce
will make your time as joyless as
possible what's the point of even
opening
it's not like you're gonna be making any
money off of this
plus it's not very clear how exactly
they're going to be enforcing the
no screaming on the ride rule perhaps
ejector seats while on the move
you